-President Trump held one of
his weirdest rallies yet
as he tries to strip away
the constitutional rights
of immigrants.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump last night
made another stop
on his Orange Collar Comedy Tour
where he held
a spectacularly unhinged rally
in South Carolina.
Now, these rallies
are very much
like public therapy sessions
for Trump,
but as things get worse for
Trump, politically and legally,
these speeches
seem to get weirder.
And last night was no exception,
because he was
all over the place.
-The Olympics
would've been a massive failure,
and it turned out
to be a massive success.
People did not want
to be nuked in a stadium.
I said,
"Listen, you got rich guys,
for whatever reason,
they love rockets."
By the way,
I have the stupid teleprompters.
You don't mind that I haven't
used them all night, do you?.
"The Apprentice" --
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
big movie star, took my place,
it bombed in about two shows.
It was over.
Mosquitos.
Lost many, many lives.
They said she got a face lift.
No.
If it's not your hair,
don't run for office, folks.
We're not looking up in the air.
Any rockets up there?
Any rockets?
You know, they call them
the elites, right?
"The elites."
You know what you are?
You're the super elites.
I'm changing titles.
-We are the super elites.
[ Laughter ]
-He is so dumb
he doesn't even understand
that "elites"
was supposed to be an insult.
"They called Democrats
out-of-touch intellectuals.
Well, I say we're
further out-of-touch
super intellectuals."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, think about all
those random topics
he just rambled on about
at an official campaign rally.
Trump isn't the president.
He's more like
one of those [bleep] algorithms
that suggest other articles
you might want to read.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you liked "build the wall,"
you might also like
the Olympics,
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
and rich guys love rockets.
[ Laughter ]
In fact,
on the topic of rockets --
can't believe I'm saying that --
but on the topic of rockets,
Trump, once again,
mumbled a few incoherent words
about his proposal
to create a sixth branch
of the military called
the Space Force.
But this rant was somehow even
harder to follow
than previous editions.
-By the way,
NASA is now open for business.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got all these guys sending
rockets all over the place.
We'll get the credit.
I said, "Lease them the land,
charge them a lot,
but let's do it that way.
That's a lot better.
We're like a landlord."
You have all these rich guys.
I don't know what it is.
They love rockets.
I said, "This is great,
'cause, you know,
you can't send rockets up, like,
down the street, right?
You can't take the local plot,
the local Walmart,
the local store,
and send a rocket.
We're gonna win.
Remember,
I said we're gonna win at trade,
we're gonna win in space.
-[ Laughing ]
The guy standing next to him's
like, "Yeah,
we're gonna win at space."
"We're gonna win at space,
and we're gonna get
to board the spaceship first
because we have
super-elite status."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But, of course...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...Trump cannot make it
through one rally
without mentioning
the 2016 election.
Now, there was a period of time
where it seemed like
his obsession
was maybe waning a little bit.
But last night,
it was like the good old days.
All you had to do was
wind him up and watch him go.
-You know, we won the state
of South Carolina by a lot.
We had to run
the whole East Coast,
and we got South Carolina,
and we got North Carolina.
We got Pennsylvania,
and we got Florida.
"Donald Trump has won
the state of Florida," right?
They said, "North Carolina
is our firewall.
South Carolina
we have no chance,
but North Carolina..."
And so we won South Carolina,
thank you very much.
-Ugh! How many times are
you gonna tell this story?!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Ugh!
Grandpa, I heard this story!"
[ Laughter ]
For Trump,
talking about the election
is how he sooths his ego,
and, yesterday,
he rambled on about it
for a very long time,
at one point even acknowledging
that he was
bragging about himself
because no one else
would do it for him.
-To win Wisconsin, which
hasn't been won in many years,
like 1972, I think.
That's a long time.
To win Michigan, which hasn't
been won in a long time.
You know, it's very interesting.
I just took this out.
Sometimes you have
to toot your own horn,
because nobody else
is gonna do it.
Certainly,
they're not gonna do it.
-Oh, you just figured that out?
[ Laughter ]
You've been putting your name
on buildings for 40 years,
and you just decided
it's time to toot your own horn?
[ Laughter ]
Also, you don't toot.
You're constantly
blowing your horn.
Your mouth is like a vuvuzela
at the World Cup.
[ Laughter ]
In facts your rallies would make
exactly the same amount of sense
if they sounded like this.
[ Vuvuzela blowing ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But Trump's rambling
about the election
somehow got weirder
because he insisted
that a lot
of Hollywood celebrities
voted for him
and decided to call out
"Twin Peaks" creator
David Lynch.
-Here's a story
that just came out.
David Lynch --
you know, the great filmmaker.
David Lynch -- he puts down --
Headlines,
"Trump could go down --"
This is a Hollywood guy.
The reason I do this is,
you know, you don't hear this --
And plenty of them voted for me.
Plenty of them voted for me.
David Lynch --
"Could go down
as one of the greatest
presidents in history."
-I mean, it's weird,
but I guess it would make sense
if David Lynch
liked Donald Trump.
Donald Trump
is like the president
from a dream sequence
in an episode of "Twin Peaks."
[ Laughter ]
[ Speaking backwards ]
Trump, of course,
also uses these rallies
to rail against
his many perceived enemies,
and one of those is
South Carolina Congressman
Mark Sanford, a Republican
who has sometimes
been critical of Trump.
Now, you might remember
that, back in 2009,
Sanford, as governor,
famously told his wife
he was hiking
on the Appalachian Trail
when, in fact,
he was having an affair,
and Trump, who always remembers
your lowest moment,
brought it up last night.
Although he couldn't remember
the correct name
for the Appalachian Trail.
-Never liked him too much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I wasn't a big fan.
The Tallahassee Trail.
Must be a beautiful place.
Unfortunately,
he didn't go there.
-The Tallahassee Trail?
That sounds like
the name of a strip club
next to the Tallahassee airport.
"Welcome to buffet night
at The Tallahassee Trail!
Shrimp is all-you-can-eat,
and it is room temperature."
[ Laughter ]
Trump, of course, also remains
obsessed with the border
and keeps lying about his
promise to build a wall there.
In March, Congress allotted some
money for border security,
but that money can be used only
to repair and build
previously approved fencing.
But when supporters broke out
into yet another chant
to build that wall, Trump
continued to falsely insist
that the wall
was already being built.
-If you don't have borders,
you don't have a country.
You don't have a country.
Oh, it's happening.
It's not
"build that wall" anymore.
It's continue
building that wall.
-"Continue building that wall."
Not only is that wrong,
it's a much worse chant.
[ Laughter ]
Although I guess
it's better than
"Continue building and repairing
that previously approved
fencing!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump also continues to use
racist, dehumanizing language
to talk about immigrants,
and now he's calling
for stripping them of their
constitutionally protected
due-process rights
and deporting them
without being able to make
their case in front of a judge.
-We want very tight,
very strict borders.
And they came to me
three days ago.
"Sir, we'd like you
to sign this order."
What is the order?
"We need 5,000 judges
on the border."
I said, "Judges?
What other country has judges?"
I said, "Where are you gonna
find 5,000 people to be judges?
How many do we have now?"
"I don't know the number."
They don't even know the number
even though
they're in charge, okay?
-No, dude, you're in charge.
[ Laughter ]
That's the deal.
That's like if your pilot
got on the PA and said,
"Okay, folks, I asked the tower
what airport we're going to,
and they said they don't know,
and I certainly don't, either."
[ Laughter ]
"So, sit back and relax,
and a special welcome aboard
to all our super-elite members.
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we go back to this
for just a second.
-We need
5,000 judges on the border.
I said, "Judges?
What other country has judges?"
-What other country has judges?
Lots of --
Most other countries.
In the Netherlands,
they even have judges
at a special court in the Hague,
and who knows -- maybe
you'll get to meet them one day.
You don't --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't know, but you might.
But Trump hasn't
always felt so cavalier
about
the due-process protections
provided by the Constitution.
He's trying to strip them away
from immigrants now,
but when his own staffers
are being investigated
as part of
the Russian investigation,
he felt very differently about
the importance of due process.
So, Trump wants to strip away
the constitutional rights
of immigrants,
but when it's his own aides
being investigated,
he suddenly sounds like a guy
being dragged away
from the buffet for trying
to put shrimp in his pockets.
"How dare you!
There's such thing any longer
as due process!
I'm never coming back
to The Tallahassee Trail!"
[ Laughter ]
Trump and the GOP
only care about
seizing political power and
using it to restrict the rights
of marginalized pe ople.
Just take Trump's Muslim ban,
which was upheld
by the Supreme Court today
in a 5-4 ruling
after Republicans installed
Justice Neil Gorsuch at a seat
that should've been filled
by President Obama.
The various versions of the ban
were so sloppy and ill-conceived
that even Trump officials,
like former White House
press secretary, Sean Spicer,
couldn't keep
their stories straight
on whether or not it was a ban.
-Well, first of all,
it's not a travel ban.
It's a 90-day ban.
I think a million people
have now come into this country.
That's not a ban.
The ban deals
with seven countries.
It can't be a ban if you're
letting a million people in.
-The President himself
called it a ban.
-I understand.
-Is he confused,
or are you confused?
-No, I'm not confused.
-Yeah, you are.
Sean Spicer
always answered questions
like a dude passed out
in the bushes
after a concert in Central Park.
"Sir, is that
a vape in your hand?"
"Uh, yeah, it's a vape.
No, I mean,
it's an inhaler, uh, for weed."
[ Laughter ]
Trump and the GOP
are trying to destroy
some of the most cherished
legal protections
at the heart of our
constitutional system.
They don't care about immigrants
or working people.
They want a system that only
works for one group of people,
and that's...
-The super elite.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]